economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela a blandón daniela muy
buenas noches ya se conoció el impacto
que tiene la pandemia del cob y 19 en el
empleo mundial a lo largo del 2020 si
santiago buenas noches mire la
organización internacional del trabajo
entregó noticias buenas y malas a
mediados del año pasado calculaba que se
habían perdido 500 millones de empleos a
nivel mundial por culpa de la pandemia
pero ahora dice que se perdió la mitad
unos 255 millones de plazas laborales de
las cuales 39 millones están en
latinoamérica esto se debió a las re
aperturas económicas que se dieron en el
segundo trimestre es una noticia buena
ahora viene la mala sigue habiendo un
impacto cuatro veces mayor al provocado
por la crisis financiera de 2009 la
cantidad de horas trabajadas cayó en 88
% también los trabajadores perdieron
ingresos por 37 billones de dólares con
la organización internacional del
trabajo pide mesura a la hora de pensar
en el futuro porque dice que la
recuperación será
desigual e incierta y que todavía no
sabemos qué va a pasar con la pandemia
daniela comenzó el foro económico
mundial en davos en suiza por primera
vez virtual sí pues se dio apertura a
una inédita semana de reuniones
bilaterales en las que se va a debatir
cómo se puede justamente recuperar el
mundo de las consecuencias de la
pandemia el presidente chino xi jinping
fue quien inauguró el evento pidiendo
evitar confrontaciones sobre comercio y
tecnología en clara referencia a eeuu
escuchemos yo como seguidor
incondicional de una política exterior
independiente y pacífica china está
trabajando arduamente para dirimir las
diferencias mediante el diálogo y
resolver las controversias mediante la
negociación así como mantener relaciones
amistosas y de cooperación con otros
países sobre la base del respeto mutuo
la igualdad y el beneficio mutuo pues el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres instó por su parte a que dentro
de esa recuperación tengan muy presente
el cambio climático tenía la seguimos
hablando de china porque
y superó a eeuu como el más grande
receptor de inversión extranjera si
santiago en todo 2020 la inversión
extranjera directa en los países se
desplomó casi a la mitad por culpa del
cob y de 19 esto según un informe de
naciones unidas y aunque la mayoría de
países puede decir que recibió menos
capital foráneo no es el caso de china
en 2020 de este país de registro 163 mil
millones de dólares y esto le permitió
superar a eeuu que tuvo apenas de 134
mil millones de dólares la razón para
que el gigante asiático superará a la
mayor potencia mundial tiene que ver con
que allí la inversión no sólo no cayó
sino que creció un poco mientras que en
eeuu cayó a la mitad como en el resto
del mundo
pnl con este panorama que usted nos
describe precisamente eeuu presentó un
plan para fortalecer la industria a
nivel local de qué se trata
santiago el presidente joe biden firmó
una orden ejecutiva para que el gobierno
federal
el mayor comprador individual de bienes
y servicios del mundo les compra a los
fabricantes estadounidenses y no a los
extranjeros escuchemos bajo la
administración anterior los contratos
del gobierno federal adjudicados
directamente a empresas extranjeras
aumentaron un 30% eso va a cambiar bajo
nuestra supervisión hoy estoy dando los
primeros pasos en mi plan de
recuperación que invierte en los
trabajadores estadounidenses sindicatos
y empresas a lo largo y ancho de la
cadena de suministro
pues esto lo hace el presidente justo en
momentos en que comienza la negociación
en el congreso sobre un gran paquete de
estímulos por 1,9 billones de dólares
hablemos ahora de las bolsas como les
fueron los principales parqués alrededor
del mundo wall street' de cerró mixto
pero con nuevos récords en los índices
de standard and poor's y nasdaq esto
gracias a las compañías tecnológicas en
europa los problemas que han tenido
algunos laboratorios en el desarrollo de
las vacunas vinieron las bolsas de rojo
y en américa latina' finalmente hubo un
descenso notable en la
de nuevo de buenos aires en medio de las
negociaciones del país con el fondo
monetario internacional para el día para
el cierre 18 millones de dólares esta
fue una multa santiago que impuso méxico
a siete bancos por realizar acuerdos
ilegales para comprar o vender productos
financieros y así establecer el precio
eso se conoce como colusión la sanción
es para nadie más y nadie menos que
barclays bank deutsche bank santander
banamex
bank of america cwa méxico y jamie moore
cat
muchas gracias daniela es todo por el
momento en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]